>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT, IT'S
TIME FOR OUR NEXT GAME, NOM DE
PLUMAGE.
NOM DE PLUMAGE.
(MORGAN WHOOPING)
HEY, GUYS, RECENTLY 211 NEW
SPECIES OF ANIMALS WERE
DISCOVERED IN THE EASTERN
HIMALAYAS, INCLUDING THIS HORROR
SHOW.
(GASPS)
ANYWAY, THANKS TO SCIENTISTS, WE
KNOW THAT THIS IS ACTUALLY A
SNUB-NOSED MONKEY AND NOT, UH,
SKELETOR IN A FUR COAT.
BUT NOT ALL ANIMALS ARE SO EASY
TO IDENTIFY.
SO, COMEDIANS, I'M GONNA SHOW
YOU A PHOTO OF AN ANIMAL, AND I
WANT YOU TO TELL ME ITS NAME.
FIRST ONE...
(BELL DINGS)
DAN.
>> THE OLD DICK-TONGUED GERBIL.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, POINTS.
UH, NEXT ONE. NEXT ONE.
(BELL DINGS)
>> OCTOCAT.
>> HARDWICK: YES, OCTOCAT.
POINTS.
UH, NEXT ONE.
(BELL DINGS)
MORGAN.
>> THAT IS THE, UH, SHAVED JAY
OAKERSON.
>> AW.
>> NO! NO!
NO POINTS FOR THAT.
THAT HURTS ME AS HIS FRIEND.
>> AW.
(AWWING)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS. NEXT ONE.
(BELL DINGS)
JAY.
>> THAT'S THE TWINS FROM THE
SHINING FERRETS.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS. YEP.
LAST ONE. LAST ONE.
(BELL DINGS)
DAN.
>> THAT'S THE LLAMA DRESSED BY
HIS MAMA.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, POINTS.
POINTS.